welcome back we are here with the
creators and stars of the new movie Lisa
Frankenstein Co spr Zelda Williams
Diablo Cody and Katherine Newton the new
movie features a young woman who much
like the original Dr Frankenstein brings
a creation to life using science in
honor of the new movie and all monster
movies out there it's time for a game
called Monster
mashup monster
M all right so
Diablo kindly agree for host take it
away do thank you Kelly I feel like Ryan
Crest right now this very exciting for
me to be hosting um in this game I will
give clues that have to do with famous
monster movies actors and so on if you
know the answer hit your button and
answer and if you're wrong the other
team can steal okay the teams are Zelda
and Cole playing for the left side of
the
audience and Kelly and Catherine playing
for the right side of the
audience
I like my team I see I see I see who's
competitive here the winner will earn
Alisa Frankenstein prize for their side
so let's go okay is it a puppy okay what
do we win puppy okay all right first
question in John cin movie a quiet place
mostly oh here we go no that's what they
said they said you could click it early
no what's the answer I don't know yet
the question has
not it sounds like we can steal I think
they get to steal I'm sorry but do we no
you have to you can interrupt the
question but then you have to know the
answer by then so let's just say Emily
Blunt okay what oh my
God no way no
way no way uh oh yeah we just you oh
yeah Feel The House Always Wins huh I
just threw out a name of a person in the
movie I thought we get to steal that's
not she's literally the only person I
could remember in the movie look let's
just take it we're going to move on next
question the monster in this movie was
Bradley witford and his family the title
is also what you yes Zelda get out
that's
right that is a see what happened when
you play fair we wouldn't have had that
that is a messed upie we would not had
that that was all you I love Bradley
Whitford I'm sorry let's go I do too
next question in the movie monster a sex
worker in Florida became a serial killer
the film won an Academy Award for what
lead
actress Charlie Stone
[Applause]
yes so good I love that movie yeah yeah
you put that away next question in what
movie were the humans hunting a monster
in the ocean only to discover that to
their dismay they were going to need a
bigger boat oh I did it first ja is that
you you're right I was like I did it
first I know
I a big
boat is this a tie I think it's it's a
tie all right next question this musical
story featured a monster that fed on
human The Rocky Horror Picture Show no
no no no no what no it's oh Little Shop
of horse shop of horse but we got to
steal it yeah that's why I'm stealing it
I'm stealing it but I said it no but
yeah you already messed up I said it at
the same time thank
you I love
it next question keep me quiet this
movie was based on a show a cartoon
actually in which a bunch of meddling
kids Scooby-Doo scoobert dobert
do
destroy next question in what movie did
two characters played by John Goodman
and Billy Crystal team up to capture the
the screams of chill um Monsters Inc
that is
[Music]
correct good damn that was good it took
me got this we got this I forgot it's
not
it's mon okay so that's good to remember
okay in what monster movie did an
escaped circus performer wait in a storm
drain it that's right mind is blow my
mind is
blow yeah is that a Time
we're tied we're tied up baby I think
we're tied up I just say that I don't
think it was affiliated with a circus
okay I'm moving on that air horn means
we have to move on to the last question
was an alien you're correct in what
movie did Merill strip and Goldie Han oh
my
godes one with
[Applause]
a thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you sir thank you for playing
thank you great job great job great job
job Sho through you all that's what it
was that's what it was oh my gosh all
right you are welcome anytime to be my
teammate in a game you are so fun and
everyone in the audience is a winner
because it's my show and I stay so
courtesy of focus featurers you're all
going home with a pair of tickets to see
Lisa
Frankenstein and everybody watching also
goes to Lisa break
theaters this
[Music]
[Applause]
Friday thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home